Pro Football Hall of Famer who helped
win one for John who won twice under pat
bones leadership of the Broncos
franchise he is Terrell Davis how you
doing TD hey good morning rich don't
okay okay you know obviously woke up
this morning to some very sad news of
Pat Bowlen passing away it you know this
is it's personal because you know I
practice not only just a very good owner
and you know loved the Broncos but I
consider him the real good friend and
you know it's tough when you lose
someone like that so it's a tough day
but trying to find a way to celebrate
his legacy and try to remember him for
the things that that he was able to
accomplish and you know it was great for
the city of Denver and Bronco country
should be proud of him and I'm certainly
in so uh it's tough but um you know
we're gonna celebrate him and obviously
I think in two months from now it'll be
enshrined in the Pro Football Hall of
Fame so that that would be a time to
celebrate it now look at his life and
the impact that he made on the Broncos
and in the city of Denver so you use the
legacy word because that is obviously a
word we talk about when people pass and
certainly people of significance like
Pat Bowen what would you describe his
legacy to be no but you know Pat was on
a number of committees so not only a
Broncos but for the NFL you know he was
instrumental in NFL Network and some of
the labor those issues and the things
that he was just you know so many
committees and he had his hand turned on
a lot of things that we kind of see
today in the NFL Sunday Night Football
sort of the packages that we now get the
chance to in a way you know he was just
a visionary he was a person that you
know I've been thinking and in a fox he
was always trying I think actually
include this and make this game better
for everybody and you know we had a
chance to experience that on a personal
level you know with the Broncos I
thought that we were always I had up
every every franchise when it came to
implementation weathers implemented uh
the deal attrition whether it was
bringing in you know biomechanic people
to kind of work on our bodies and
you know I just saw thought like he was
always thinking to the informer thinking
and what he was was trying to bring
their present and he always you know
some competitor but always wanted you
just every tool an asset that we can we
can have to be successful and when you
have an owner who's willing to do
everything for you and not really
looking at the dollars and cents but
look at it from a standpoint of hey this
just makes sense this is what the
players need I'm gonna provide that to
him and you know kind of treatments and
a family you feel that you feel when her
owner this junior within in his concerns
about your family and things that you do
want a personal personal basis and you
know you don't
yeah I got it I didn't think that was
normal so you know my friendship with
him you know it's deep and sincerely you
know I was gonna miss him and but it's
you know again I gotta say at the time
to celebrate his life and what he's
meant I remember I came to dinner I only
had one idea pet bowl and I was watching
the old clip so you know the drive and
you kind of see him pat on the side with
that sort of code and you know you kind
of have this one idea of a person I just
a few questions you think I own not sure
what to expect me is when I got to
Denver but he was a total opposite of
what kind of a you know the media
portrayed him to be he was outgoing it's
funny he was very engaging he was a
family man he treated you with respect
no matter what level you are in the
organization
he was very approachable you had access
to all three hours a day go to the
office go there and you know it was just
really cool I just I thought appendage
has been a real cool guy and you know
and it did put business before you know
feeling he was a be was it was business
to friend but it was it was personal you
know was on a personal choice doing that
you just kind of felt like he didn't
yeah I know he was in business but he
makes you feel like it was family and
that's that takes so you know that
that's the best skill you know that's
something that you have to acquire and
when you walk away stand pat you just
feel like that everybody cares about me
as a person and that that that's what
yet Terrell Davis Hall of Famer here on
the Rich Eisen show cool that's the word
I said last hour that day that's the
word for him cool I always felt like man
that guy was cool and every time I had
an exchange with him I'm like as he
walked away and I watched him kind of
like mosey away in leather jacket or
whatever he was in or one of those sport
coats I'm like man that was cool he is
so cool right and and you know I didn't
play for him like you but I broadcast
for him and we all at the NFL Network at
the very beginning TD Lee you know when
you start something new you're hoping
it's working out you're hoping that
those who are in charge like it or what
have you I never felt like there that
this could fold or it wasn't gonna work
as I always thought Pat Bowlen wouldn't
let it happen I really felt that way and
obviously Steve Bornstein our immediate
boss and the commissioner were always
very integral in Roger Goodell
at the time too but because of his
support I never thought that there was
any problem with that I'm wondering what
that was like to play for somebody who I
assume created the same atmosphere yeah
absolutely and that's and that's not a
chance to experience it on a small level
but to be an ability to come by like
that every day and to know what he was
building and what he was what is this
idea of what a franchise looks like you
know the words I was always I guess one
of the words was classy but he'd always
talked about first class everything was
like in the first class manner and so
you kind of had this idea that no meat
don't spare no expense to make sure that
he's doing everything in the first class
man oh yeah just like you know what you
start with you say like back when the
inner core network first started when I
was there right and he would come up
there and you know he was partly
responsible for you know I'm probably a
lot of responsible for me being on the
network you know in the early stages but
to have an owner I don't know like I
said one of the things I would I would
say I was playing is that then I hear
from a lot of guys in play they talk
about sometimes I wonder what it's like
to play some other friends
while their planned for a current their
current team I've never had to think
about that because I thought that disk
was but you know I was sitting there
with the best franchise the best owner
so I never had ever thought about I
don't know what I thought the place to
tell them why is that
never thought about that because when
you have it so good
warned you already you don't never allow
that thought to enter your bearings you
know but the other people come to dinner
and they would always compliment us and
or comment on I can't believe you guys
guy like this here and when you look at
franchises that are successful just look
at the ownership look at the ownership
that that's that's the that's the spear
that's where it starts it starts up top
and it circles down and everything
that's happened in Denver from but the
winning percentage I mean you know 300
wins at first 30 years
the Super Bowl appearances the
championship all of that stuff
it starts with Pat Bowlen starts with
the ownership so that that to tell you a
lot about mr. B and you know
occasionally when I went through all my
surgery 19 others 99 after Tom a skill
you know the first phone privacy when I
came out of surgery what's in that
bowling so that that tells you all the
type of man he is
you know to care by to and it was a
genuine concern I wasn't just up past
and I don't call you a generic name or
number he'd come with you by your name
ask you questions about your family did
is it's homework to integral of his way
to make sure you know everything about
you and yes imagine how that feels as a
player you know when he has to go all
the players on his master and he did a
great turn up of engaged in players and
making him feel special and you know I
can't say enough great things about that
forward yeah and I asked this question I
know it's a sensitive one to TD Terrell
Davis here and the Richard show did he
know that he was enshrined that he was
voted into the Hall of Fame do you know
if he knew 2017 when I went up and you
know I did my private speech I bet you
that you know I was like hey you know
it's part time they put Pat in the Hall
of Fame because I did was helpless
failing and I wanted to make sure that
he recognized that he was aware what was
happening and that was important to me
and so I I don't know if
was aware of that I certainly I
certainly hope he was you know but I
don't know I have no way of knowing that
but uh you know I hope wherever he is it
is just looking down on us right now
that he could certainly look back and be
proud of himself
because we certainly are a pilot at
Boeing and obviously they're trying to I
think it's been too much about yep oh
did a chance to look down that event and
I just smiled I was gonna say how
special is that weekend gonna be in
Canton the celebration there for
elephant champ champ doing interview I
mean it's gonna be a whole big Broncos
Palooza
TD oh yeah it's just a city boy it'll be
a broccoli do it the way you know it's
gonna be a fun time to celebrate his
life and his legacy and I'll be there
yeah I'm sort of Polanco countries don't
come in and intro and the Broncos will
be there too playing the Falcons in the
Hall of Fame Game
so it'll be the entire organization in
obviously you and John and the rest of
the Broncos that have been enshrined and
that will include officially come August
Pat Bowlen who passed away at the age of
75 overnight thanks for the call TD
appreciate it
no problem [ __ ] do the best be the best
thanks for the call
that's the Terrell Davis Hall of Famer
two-time Super Bowl champion Super Bowl
MVP and all-around great individual for
more of the Rich Eisen show tune -
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for free
on BR Live or download the Rich Eisen
show app